seht ihr das wie viele Gemüse man im
Februar schon im Haus oder sogar draußen
im Garten aussehen kann also schnappt
euch eure saatguthütchen und dann machen
wir die Februar Auszeit zusammen und wir
starten mit dem Weißkohl das hier ist
die Sorte Nuggets früh weiß ich sage
immer auch die Sorten dazu die sich bei
uns bewährt haben und auch um diese
Jahreszeit bewährt haben und ich benutze
wie immer solche Eisstäbchen hier zum
Beschriften einerseits weil die schön
billig sind und andererseits weil man
die dann auch mit der Pflanze nach
draußen Pflanzen kann und dann können
die im Beet verrotten ohne dass man sich
irgendwie Sorgen machen muss und ich
sehe fast alle cool gewechselt immerhin
ein Schälchen aus und wenn die dann die
ersten richtigen Blätter nach dem
Keimblättern bekommen haben sind die
groß genug um pikiert zu werden das
heißt dass dann jede einzelne Pflanze
mit einem Stäbchen rausgehoben wird und
in ein eigenes Töpfchen reingesetzt wird
bleiben wir mal beim Kohlgemüse als
nächstes kommt der Kohlrabi da sehe ich
die Sorte als du es da aus das ist eine
lila Farben richtig tolle Sorte die
sieht wunderschön schön aus und ihr
könnt euch auch schon mal freuen wenn
ihr bei meinem saatgutabo mit dabei seid
das startet Ende März oder Anfang April
werden wir die erste saatgutbox
versenden und gleich die Sorte als du es
da auch in der ersten Box mit dabei ja
von baue ich ein bisschen mehr an
deswegen nehme ich hier gleich zwei
Töpfchen und ein Rotkohl kommt bei mir
auch noch in die anzuchtschale dann
nehme ich die Sorte Granat die haben wir
auch schon sehr oft angebaut und sehr
gerne gerade jetzt in der 100 Tage
Selbstversorger Challenge die wenn das
Video rauskommt dann auch vorbei ist
seit ein paar Tagen habe ich sehr sehr
gerne Rotkraut gegessen also ich habe
das der richtig lieben gelernt vorher
mochte ich das gar nicht so gerne aber
schon schön das im eigenen Garten
anbauen zu können also wenn wir davon
auch was aus machen wir mit dem Salat
weiter und muss sie dann so drauflegen
genau
Salat nicht mit der Erde bedecken oder
höchstens ein ganz bisschen mit Erde
bedecken weil Salat ist nämlich ein
Lichtkeimer und sonst können die nicht
keimen und da habe ich jetzt die Sorte
Biela ausgesetzt aber ich werde gleich
noch ein paar andere Sorten schießen
weil ich nämlich finde dass es schön ist
so eine bunte Salatmischung zu haben
deswegen kommt noch mehr weh de
cut-saison und die Sorte Augsburg als
wäre ich jetzt auch noch raus das ist so
richtig schöner grüner Salat und ich
habe übrigens hier noch so neue
anzuchttöpfchen die ich ausprobieren
wollte weil wir auch unseren Onlineshop
jetzt bald starten und sich ganz viele
von euch Alternativen zu Plastik
gewünscht haben und ich finde die
quickpots richtig praktisch mit den
Gärtner ich jetzt auch schon eine ganze
Weile und ich bin ein großer Fan von
denen das hier war ein großer Eck die
alle mit Erde zu befüllen weil die ähm
alle einzeln muss man die rausholen mit
Erde befüllen und dann wieder reinsetzen
das hat schon eine knappe Stunde
gedauert würde ich sagen aber sieht
natürlich viel schöner aus und ist viel
nachhaltiger aber Plastik ist wobei man
die quickbots ja auch immer wieder
verwenden kann also mal gucken ob die
sich bewähren oder nicht wir haben noch
einen Salat das ist die wintermarin
die wintermarie ist eine tolle
Alternative zu dem Salat den wir
übrigens auch versuchen mit in einer
Saatgut Kiste reinzunehmen ist noch
nicht ganz klar wann wir das schaffen
weil der erst noch angebaut werden muss
da der wird auf jeden Fall auch mit dem
Saatgut Abo auftauchen ich habe noch gar
nicht gewässert also die Erde habe ich
schon bevor ich das Video gefilmt habe
angefeuchtet das heißt sie ist schön
feucht und den Salat drücke ich jetzt
einfach nur an weil wenn ich jetzt
Gießen würde dann würden die Samen
vielleicht irgendwo anders hinfließen
aber das ganze Kohlgemüse gießen wir
jetzt noch mit der Ball raus an die hat
so einen richtig schönen feinen Strahl
und da muss man sich dann keine Sorgen
machen dass die Erde irgendwie sonst
wohin schwimmt und die Ballbrause ist im
Gewächshaus Freunde deswegen können wir
jetzt hier vielleicht mal einblenden wie
das aussehen wird der Trend geht zur
zweiten Ballbrause oh wir haben noch
einen coolen Gemüse was kommt als
nächstes das ist der Blumenkohl sehr
sehr ich jetzt die Sorte Amabile aus ich
hoffe man spricht diese aus das ist
einfach eine sehr frühe Sorte Chili
könnt ihr jetzt auch aussehen ich habe
aber so viele Chili noch getrocknet dass
ich dieses Jahr keine anbauen werde
stattdessen mache ich weiter mit der
Paprika meine absolute Lieblingssorte
ist die wonder Paprika die Macht so
richtige glockenförmige Paprika also
früher habe ich immer Paprika angebaut
die so spitz waren im Garten und
ziemlich dünnwandig ich wusste das lange
Zeit gar nicht dass man auch so ganz
normale glockenförmige Paprika wie man
die aus dem Laden kennt wer sich zu
Hause anbauen kann Paprika sehe ich
jetzt jeder einen eigenes Töpfchen
einfach weil das auch größere Pflanzen
sind die werden trotzdem am Ende noch
pikiert in größeres Töpfchen weiß ja
noch eine ganze Weile dauert bis Mitte
Mai bis sie danach draußen wandern kann
auch zwei Samenkörner in einen Topf
reinmachen dann ist man auf der sicheren
Seite das eine Pflanze aufgeht aber man
kann auch nur eins nehmen natürlich beim
Aussehen auch immer die außer Tiefe
beachten die ist bei jedem Gemüse ein
bisschen anders es sollte eigentlich
immer auf den Samen Tütchen mit drauf
stehen ich ziehe im Sommer auf meinen
Bauernhof um deswegen habe ich schon
viel hin und her überlegt welche
Pflanzen ich überhaupt jetzt hier in
diesem Garten noch anbauen möchte damit
ich überhaupt noch ernten kann ich denke
bei dem Kohl wird das schon noch klappen
sonst behalte ich den Garten auch
einfach noch ein bisschen länger und
fahre dann noch mal hierher und Ernte
alles ab diese Pflanze hier ist schon
komplett für die neuen Bauernhof ich
glaube ich würde versuchen die auch da
dann schon zu pflanzen sind Artischocken
ich liebe Artischocken klar brauchen die
viel Platz aber ich will auf jeden Fall
ganz viele die schocken auf meinem Hof
haben ich liebe die Sorten green Glow
und Imperial Star die sind beide
ziemlich toll habe ich auch beide schon
mehrmals angebaut wer hat die schocken
ist es so dass die nicht unbedingt im
ersten Jahr schon blühen wie man ist ja
die Blüten dann die Knospen sozusagen da
muss man sich manchmal ein bisschen
gedulden meine Erfahrung nach ist es so
dass wenn man mehrere Pflanzen hat
irgendwie schon eine dabei ist die schon
im ersten Jahr wenigstens ein paar
Blüten liefert deswegen brauche ich
einfach ganz viele an Leute zusammen ein
bisschen schwer die zu überwintern über
dem Boden abschneiden bevor es richtig
kalt wird und dann einfach ein paar mehr
anbauen als man braucht weil meistens
ein paar erfrieren im Winter ich sehe
diesen Sommer um deswegen
eigentlich wollte ich noch Löwenmäulchen
aussehen aber mein Saatgut ist leer und
ich habe dieses Jahr zum ersten Mal
keinen Saatgut bestellt im Frühling weil
wir ja jetzt mit dem Wurzelwerk seid gut
starten und ich dachte dann habe ich ja
immer genug und jetzt sehe ich noch
Spinat aus den ich dann demnächst ins
Gewächshaus Pflanze das muss man nicht
machen man könnte ihn auch direkt sehen
empfehle ich sogar normalerweise eher
aber Gewächshaus wurden gerade noch
meine Enten und die würden die natürlich
sofort weg snacken und platt trampeln
deswegen mache ich das jetzt hier im
Haus und dann kann ich später nach
draußen getrennt werden und die sollte
Dich ja auch sehr heißt übrigens gamazon
wenn das gleiche Spiel machen wir auch
mit dem Mangold der kommt auch ins
Gewächshaus und deswegen ziehe ich den
im Haus vorbei weil ich da jetzt einfach
noch gerade keinen Platz für die Aussaat
habe und dann nehme ich die Sorte voll
Rio ich habe fast vergessen was richtig
richtig ist ein ganz tolles Gemüse die
Aubergine die konnte mir das passieren
ich habe gerade noch so zwei Töpfchen
vom Balkon geholt und die mit fünf
fertigen schon fast gefüllt in dem kann
man auch sehr gut aussehen und dann
machen wir die natürlich auch noch da
baue ich ganz gerne die Sorte Zora an
die Macht richtig schön große Früchte
und die Sorte ich will immer Barben
Tante sagen Jackie aus meinem Team hat
das irgendwann mal gesagt und seitdem
geht mir das nicht mehr aus dem Kopf die
sollte heißt eigentlich
würde ich sagen vielleicht spricht man
es auch ganz anders aus ich will
versuchen bevor ich umziehen noch schön
viele Auberginen im Gewächshaus zur
ernten also kommt jetzt auch noch in die
Erde ich liebe Aubergine UPS eigentlich
sollte man die Holzstäbchen immer mit
einem Bleistift beschriften weil die
andere Farbe sonst abwäscht auch bei
Kugelschreiber aber mein Bleistift ist
weg also wir haben die Zora und Tante
ich habe echt Baden Tante auf im Februar
kann man auch die ersten Tomaten
Aussehen ich fange da immer erstmal mit
denen an die ich später ins Gewächshaus
Pflanze aber weil Tomaten irgendwie so
ein großes eigenes Thema sind mache ich
dazu jetzt gleich noch ein eigenes Video
also folgt gerne meinem Kanal damit ihr
das nicht verpasst und drückt dann immer
auch die Glocke damit ihr eine
Benachrichtigung bekommt sobald ein
neues Video erscheint es gibt noch zwei
Sachen die ich in meinem Garten dieses
Jahr nicht anbauen möchte auch wegen dem
Umzug und so weiter das ist einmal der
Lauch da würde ich jetzt wenn ich es
machen würde die Sorte Hilari aussehen
und dann später die Sorte blaugrüner
Winter dann könnt ihr jetzt auch
Physalis vorziehen und meine
Lieblingssorte ist die Sorte
Schönbrunner Gold und jetzt gehen wir
raus in den Garten da können wir nämlich
auch schon einiges aussehen und Pflanzen
so viel im Jahr fange ich am liebsten
mit den Ärzten dann ist auch so mein
heimliches Lieblingsgemüse weil Erbsen
aus dem eigenen Beet einfach viel
leckerer schmecken als die die man so
aus dem Laden kennt und die Zuckererbsen
vertragen fast immer noch so ein
bisschen besser als die anderen Erbsen
deswegen fange ich am liebsten so früh
im Jahr mit der Zuckererbse Ambrosia an
das ist eine sehr sehr leckere Sorte und
die könnt ihr jetzt je nach Wetterlage
schon direkt nach draußen ins Bett gehen
achtet natürlich immer auf den
Wetterbericht gerade so früh im Jahr
also die ganzen Gemüse die ich euch
jetzt hier vor Modelle die vertragen
auch später noch Frost aber wenn der
Boden gerade gefroren ist oder wenn
sagen wir eine Woche nach der Aussaat
schon wieder richtig viel Schnee
angesagt ist dann bringt es natürlich
nicht so früh im Jahr schon zu sehen das
heißt da immer so ein bisschen abwägen
wie es bei euch gerade aussieht man kann
Gemüse so früh im Jahr auch vor den
kühlen Temperaturen ein bisschen
einmummeln und schützen zum Beispiel mit
einem winterschutzvlies da gibt's
einfach Gärtner Fliese die man über das
Gemüse oder über die Aussaaten drüber
machen kann um da einfach so ein
bisschen zu isolieren man kann auch gut
mit Strohm Mulchen so früh im Jahr weil
das die Pflanzen auch noch so ein
bisschen einpackt und vor den kühlen
Temperaturen schützt dann gibt es auch
ein paar karottensorten die man jetzt
schon aussehen kann nicht alle Karotten
funktioniert schon im Februar aber z.B
die Sorte Gonsenheimer treibt die bei
euch richtig gerne ganz früh oder ganz
spät im Jahr an weil die mit kühleren
Temperaturen gut klar kommt und auch
weil die sehr schnell weg die wird
einfach nicht so lang und das ist eine
tolle Karotte um die so früh anzu und
dann möglichst früh im Jahr auch ernten
zu können die meisten Leute die gerade
erst anfangen zu gärtnern wissen das gar
nicht aber die Zeit zwischen sagen wir
april und Anfang Juni ist die Zeit im
Jahr wo man am allerwenigsten erntet gar
nicht unbedingt der Winter weil da gibt
es noch richtig viele Wintergemüse die
man ernten kann aber dann danach wenn
das Wintergemüse in die Blüte geht und
das Sommergemüse noch nicht fertig ist
ist die Zeit wo man echt spärlich aus
dem Garten erntet da gibt's so ein paar
Blattgemüse die man dann schon ernten
kann aber wenn man es hinkriegt so früh
im Jahr schon z.B Karotten anzubauen
dann kann es sein dass die Erntezeit
schon in diese Periode fällt und das ist
natürlich super schön ihr könnt jetzt
auch Spinat Aussehen ich sehe am
liebsten die Sorte Winter riesen oder
wer die aus die könnt ihr auch einfach
direkt ins Bett setzen man kann
natürlich all die Gemüse auch in einem
Frühbeet Kasten oder im Gewächshaus
anbauen wenn ihr sowas habt dann wachsen
die noch ein bisschen schneller und sind
ein bisschen früher Ernte reif aber den
Spinat könnt ihr auch einfach
ungeschützt jetzt ins Freiland sehen
wenn ihr die richtig Worte nehmen jetzt
habe ich mal etwas was wahrscheinlich
wenige von euch kennen es gibt ja sehr
viele asiatische Kohlgemüse und da könnt
ihr jetzt zum Beispiel BAK Choi aussehen
die wachsen auch meistens ziemlich
schnell es ist mal was anderes meistens
Sachen die man auch nicht einfach so im
Laden kriegt die trotzdem super lecker
sind und viele dieser asiatischen
Kohlgemüse sind eben sehr Frost hat
deswegen probiert das auf jeden Fall mal
aus dann haben wir noch eine zweite
Leguminose hier im Angebot das ist die
dicke Bohne die können auch heutzutage
nur noch sehr wenig Leute da weiß das so
ein tolles Gemüse die kann man auch sehr
früh im Jahr ernten also die füllt auch
wieder diese Ernte Lücke und die könnt
ihr jetzt auch einfach direkt ins
Freiland sehen ich sehe die oft gerne
schon im Spätsommer aus weil die dann
weniger vom Blattläusen befallen werden
aber es ist auch gar kein Problem die
jetzt im Frühling anzubauen und die sind
auch richtig Frost hat also die stecken
dass sie weg das nächste Gemüse wächst
auch super schnell das sind die
Radieschen das ist auch gerade schön
wenn man mit Kindern gehört hat weil die
am meistens noch so ein bisschen
ungeduldiger gesundheitsweh Erwachsenen
meine allerliebste Sorte ist die Sora
aber man kann so früh im Jahr auch noch
die French backfirst anbauen es ist auch
eine sehr hübsche Sorte die ich auch
ganz gerne anbaue der Februar ist ein
Monat in dem es draußen aber noch viel
mehr zu tun gibt als nur die Aussaaten
zu machen es geht nämlich jetzt wieder
richtig los und wenn ihr wissen wollt
welche Garten Aufgaben jetzt gerade
anstehen dann schaut gerne in dem Video
da drüben vorbei ansonsten geht raus und
macht die Welt ein bisschen grüner und
wir sehen uns nächsten Samstag um 10 Uhr
wieder für ein neues Video macht's gut
bis dann tschüss